for the children here it's hard to
understand that three boys they've grown
up with are gone after school they came
to say goodbye Lacey Ray knew the 11
year old boy who died
I was in form today and I I couldn't
non-stop thinking about what happened to
him
um and then last period when I was in
maths I started bursting out with tears
and I had to go right outside
it was really kind quite cheeky and um
he was really nice to be honest
many of the messages here are for Jack
Johnson the ten-year-old who died trying
to help the other boys we used to be our
best mates at school we used to um
tall flight had tackle's our favorite
game but now that I know he's passed
yeah we're missing the deaths have been
felt Way Beyond this close-knit
community the manager of Birmingham city
came to lay a wreath on behalf of his
Club
for the police who tried so hard to save
the boys their loss feels personal
they left to Applause people here know
the Emergency Services did everything
they could divers have again been
searching the lake they'll keep looking
until they're certain no one else fell
in the loss of life here has been the
starkest reminder of the dangers of icy
water
as the hours go by people here are just
desperately hoping for some good news
from the hospital where the six-year-old
boy who was pulled from the lake is
being treated and remains in a critical
condition
there is a sense that what happened on
Sunday has changed this community now
having to adjust to life with three
children missing Becky Johnson Sky News
solihull